nos piden resolver para x y nos dan la
ecuación raíz cuadrada de 5x cuadrada
menos 8 es igual a 2x ya tenemos la
expresión con el radical de un lado del
lado izquierdo y lo más fácil ahora es
elevar al cuadrado ambos lados de la
ecuación elevamos al cuadrado entonces
el lado izquierdo y elevamos al cuadrado
el lado derecho aquí que tenemos si
tenemos el cuadrado de la raíz cuadrada
de 5 x cuadra a menos 8 esto es
directamente 5x cuadrada menos 8 que es
igual a 2x elevado al cuadrado es 2 al
cuadrado por x al cuadrado que es 4 x
cuadrada ya tenemos aquí una ecuación
cuadrática vamos a simplificar la aún
más para resolver le vamos a pasar las x
cuadradas de un solo lado restemos 4x
cuadrada a ambos lados o no vamos
mejorar restar menos 5x cuadrada para
facilitarnos las cosas préstamos menos
5x cuadrada del lado izquierdo y
restamos menos 5x cuadrada del lado
derecho que nos resulta entonces 5x
cuadrada con menos 5 x cuadradas
cancelan por eso estamos haciendo esto
nos queda menos 8 que es igual a 4x
cuadrada menos 5x cuadrada es menos una
x cuadrada o simplemente menos equis
cuadrada ahora que hacemos bien vamos a
multiplicar por menos 1 ambos lados de
la ecuación para que se cancelen los
signos menos o podríamos dividir entre
menos 1 que es exactamente lo mismo
entonces multiplicamos por menos 1 el
lado izquierdo y multiplicamos por menos
1 el lado derecho el lado izquierdo
resulta 8 y del lado derecho es x
cuadrada ahora vamos a tomar raíz
cuadrada a ambos lados de la ecuación
nos queda raíz cuadrada de x cuadrada es
igual a la raíz cuadrada de 8 estamos
tomando la raíz cuadrada principal a
ambos lados de la ecuación del lado
derecho nos queda x y del lado izquierdo
vamos a sacar la raíz cuadrada de 8
vamos a escribir 8 como 2 por 4 así es
que vamos a tener aquí la raíz cuadrada
de 2 por 4 lo cual podemos escribir como
la raíz cuadrada de 2 por la raíz
cuadrada de 4 no me gusta este verde
esto sigue siendo igual a x bien sabemos
que la raíz cuadrada de 4 es igual a 2
por lo que ahora tenemos 2 este término
lo estoy poniendo por delante 2 por raíz
de 2 esto es igual a x vamos a verificar
ahora que esta es la solución de la
ecuación original
sustituyamos x en el lado izquierdo de
la ecuación el lado izquierdo nos
resulta en 5 que multiplica a x al
cuadrado x que es 2 raíz de 2 elevado al
cuadrado menos 8 ya eso le saco la raíz
cuadrada me estoy enfocando solo del
lado izquierdo esto resulta entonces en
la raíz cuadrada de 5 que multiplica 2
al cuadrado es igual a 4 y esto que
multiplica raíz de 2 al cuadrado que es
2 ya esto le restamos menos 8 y ahora
tenemos 5 por 4 20 por 2 40 menos 8 32
esto es igual a la raíz cuadrada de 32
la raíz cuadrada 32 es igual a la raíz
cuadrada de 16 por 2 la raíz cuadrada y
664 así es
sería la recua de 16 por la raíz
cuadrada de 2 y 4 por raíz cuadrada de 2
es lo que obtenemos cuando sustituimos
el valor de x en el lado izquierdo de la
ecuación recuerda que la ecuación
original no estaba elevada al cuadrado
solo era la parte en verde la raíz de 5
x cuadra menos 8 veamos cuál es el valor
de 2x originalmente lado derecho es 2x
elevamos al cuadrado posteriormente para
resolver la ecuación a cuánto equivale
entonces 2 x 2 x equivale a 2 x 2 raíz
de 2 y esto es igual a 2 por 2 4 raíz de
2 ya habíamos visto que cuando x es
igual a 2 raíz de 2 el lado izquierdo
también es 4 raíz de 2 a 4 que cuando
empezamos el lado izquierdo se veía como
esto no tenía los cuadrados no habíamos
elevado al cuadrado borramos esto y así
era como estaba originalmente la
ecuación cuando sustituimos esto el lado
izquierdo obtuvimos 4 raíz de 2 y cuando
lo sustituimos del lado derecho también
obtuvimos 4 raíz de 2
así es que definitivamente esto estaba
en negro definitivamente esta es la
solución de la ecuación